people have broken the doors outside and
because of security the police have
asked us to close the show we apologize
to you this is nothing to do with us
these are the crowds that had formed
outside making it too dangerous for the
show to go on
afro beats artist ashake was performing
at the O2 Academy in Brixton but only
got through three songs according to an
eyewitness
Emergency Services responded to reports
of crowds forcing entry into the venue
as the situation escalated this happened
one woman is pushed by an officer she
falls down the steps to the floor the
Mets say the incident will be reviewed
as they continue to investigate the
events that unfolded I'm sure you can
appreciate this is still a fast move in
an evolving picture
um
involving and we're working to establish
the the events that led up to last
night's incident
we're also aware of a vast amount of
footage being shared on social media and
of course this will be examined as part
of the investigation along with
body-worn video that officers have as
well
a key question is how did these crowds
form it's believed many people in the
crowd didn't have tickets to the gig
attempts were made to Fourth Century
into the venue and the sheer numbers
meant that security at the venue
struggled to cope
a total of eight people were taken to
hospital with crushing injuries three
remain in critical condition I could see
like there were police there there was
kind of some pushing shoving people like
yelling I could see police kind of
trying to push people out of the O2 or
stop them from getting in you could see
like the glass on the window as well was
broken
um so I wasn't sure what was happening I
thought like
um kind of went to the worst conclusion
even when there's a big crowds
dispersing and people are hanging on the
street the police don't show up people
eventually do disperse but they just
didn't disperse
local MP Florence echelomie has
criticized the organizers and venue in a
tweet she said it is very clear
ticketing and security procedures have
not performed as they should have for
this incident to have occurred this is a
deeply concerning incident and has
turned an experience which should have
been a celebration into a very sad day
it will be a day those affected will
want answers for a day that will be
difficult to forget Aisha zahid Sky News